the name of the presentation is promise
of Mathematica and DOD operations
research and I'm William Lewis the
person who's supposed to give it if
anyone's in the wrong place this is your
chance to go okay nobody apparently so
let's let's kick it off this is going to
be a pretty straightforward presentation
especially compared to my next one which
is across the way in the Illinois room
which is not going to be straight
forward this is essentially a briefing
on what operations research on a fairly
low level is like in the US Department
of Defense now I'm going to be reading a
lot of this because I like my own prose
so let's go
working operations research is a very
mixed bag academic operations research
functions have already been applied
wherever they can be applied as vendor
supply packages that are programs of
record that I can't touch so most of the
academic over functions are things I
never use
they've already been used most of the
most of the current work that you
actually run into is in data acquisition
estimation and including data cleansing
and finding out how to hook up to the
local computer system
finding the right mathematics to use and
then writing the software the analyst
must be a generalist simply because the
set of problems is pretty much undefined
the generalist uses general knowledge to
select mathematical approaches that
Mathematica then implements so I
remember things that I heard about or
read about that ought to apply look them
up in Mathematica learn how to use the
mathematical functions and then apply
them in this presentation we'll give
three examples of DoD operations or
search work and it draws some general
conclusions about the usefulness of
Mathematica
we're yeah we're going to talk about
three grand projects which will range
from not very much use of Mathematica to
considerably use of Mathematica project
number one what is the function what is
the fundamental design objective of
service-oriented architecture what it's
about what in the world is it supposed
to accomplish surprisingly enough almost
nobody knows this no seriously
you'll see second project can you
control the stochastic process that has
a non normal distribution Six Sigma
assumes that does that you have a not
normal distribution but quite a few
processes don't I'm going to talk about
one that has a log normal distribution
actually except that have a set of such
processes that have a nun or a log
normal distribution okay and the third
is how can you check voluminous
regulations for consistency in order to
do that you have to locate text that
talks about the same thing and then
compare text and location a with text
and location B and we'll see how to do
that again this relies heavily on
Mathematica okay
first operations research example
service-oriented architecture it took
about six months to do the question was
very simple what is service oriented
architecture intended to do and the
answer is as far as I can tell to avoid
the frieze that makes previous software
architectures impossible to change or
maintain after a decade or two and
inoperable shortly after they become
impossible to maintain although there's
a brief interval when the software did
can't be changed is known to be wrong
but it's still complied with simply as
an authoritative source so if you're
looking for AI to take over reality it
happened a long time ago especially in
social security ok next question next
question is service oriented
architecture needed and the answer there
is yes we have a generation of corporate
research management software huge
that's becoming unstable this this
software should be replaced by
service-oriented architecture okay-y
service-oriented architecture was
intended to and actually could implement
a market metaphor and Marcus persist
indefinitely without big ball of mud
freeze in other words they went from an
architecture that has to have big ball
of mud freeze to one that historically
has been shown not to be subject to that
now a big bowl of mud freeze refers to
the gradual loss of structure under
maintenance changes this gradual loss of
structure leaves the software with as
little organization as a big ball of mud
hence the offense the name you can look
up big ball of mud in Wikipedia if you
want to that's a very good metaphor
after the after all structure is lost
after all organization has lost any
change including bugfixes introduces
more than one bug so the more you
maintain it the worse you get at that
point the software is frozen and all
changes cease including maintenance and
it gradually becomes so irrelevant to
reality that the workaround stopped
working and then it's completely
obsolete and nothing can be done okay
question cancel really delivered what it
promises answer not the way it's not in
its present form no the implementation
and introduction was fouled up I'm
afraid it was unsuccessful now in its
present form so service-oriented
architecture so ax is used to build
opaque monolithic systems by engineers
and design designed to be a design using
waterfall methods to be in its final
shape from the day it opens designed by
architects and implemented by engineers
and understood by nobody else big ball
of sorry
okay and if that happens then the big
ball of mud freezes inevitable however
given the framework and motivated
administrators so it could implement the
market that would resist big ball of mud
freeze in other words if anyone were
actually one interested in doing it then
they could be accomplished we could get
away from software that eventually
becomes unusable and too expensive to
replace here's how it works
service-oriented architecture is
intended to support a free market and
services and data in other words
everything every transaction if you want
data transformed if you want to if you
want your data transformed by another
node that is selling the transformation
service then you request the service and
you actually pay something for it if you
want data then you pay for that also
there's a contract involved that tells
you how much data you want can get for
each try how much how it's going to be
formatted how often you can try for
months the response time all this good
stuff at least in the classical
implementation that doesn't typically
isn't typically done ok such a market
framework where information and
transformation or bought and sold needs
frameworks for product definition and
for legally enforceable contracts if
someone doesn't pay you have to be able
to enforce it in the courts or enforce
it somehow it also needs a category of
administrators that are familiar with
running such a market in other words the
administrators have to say not gee the
software guys have it we'll just
complain to them he has to say we will
write a contract through direct
negotiations with whoever has the
service if it's something novel or by
looking through their catalogue if it's
not something novel administrators
simply aren't used to that and regarding
it as a bit of well regarded as well
outside their responsibilities so a
Kadri of administrators who would
actually do something like that would be
sorry for such a market neither of
frameworks nor administrators nor plans
to develop either exist I personally
know no serious development work in this
direction nor given the generally anti
market mentality of most software
companies is serious development work
likely in my opinion okay
in this study Mathematica was used only
to determine the load characteristics of
the Enterprise Service bus which is the
communications means by which the
services are requested delivered
contracts are delivered and so on the
conclusions service so it can be okay
and the conclusion there was that so it
could be safely configured as a
hierarchical Network it didn't have any
pathological distributions that would
have choked the network up and made it
impossible to work ok questions on this
if any what's going on is very simple
okay first the analysis was independent
of the form of the messages I was just
looking at what happens if you stacked
so a systems hierarchically so let's say
you had a national system or a regional
system and it went into a global system
how would the second and third orders of
the hierarchy react and again I didn't
find any bottlenecks ok so that's the
first one second thing is that marshal
Saxe back I believe in the 1600s he was
the Grand Marshal of
the kingdom of France at the time said
that people who did not know what to do
will do what they know and this is
what's happened with service-oriented
architecture it's been used to build a
system with which the designers and
architects are familiar this is largely
because the Oasis and the oMG group did
not properly explain the pressing need
for Silla and why in the world everyone
should should have a market instead so
the people who implemented it were left
saying you know another bad idea why
should we jump through hoops just
because these guys and besides it make a
really good hierarchical system so let's
go that way and they're right it does
help the administer it does help the
engineers and the and the architectures
architects but what it does not do is
avoid big ball of mud freeze human
condition okay so there that's one
instance of that's one instance of
operations real actual operations
research work ok so let's try something
else
we're going to have to step through this
a little bit more quickly ok process
control the trouble with process control
is that typically what you're
controlling doesn't yield their real
number or an integer or anything like
that it yields a range of values and
sometimes the range of values are
outside of what the quality control will
accept if if that happens if that's the
case then the question is whether you
change the settings on the machine or
tell your subordinates to do something
else or the equivalent or you don't and
it's in practice if you change every
time there's something that isn't
accepted by quality control then you end
up what's called chasing the mean and
you can end up almost anywhere if you do
that it's a good way to get into trouble
the problem is largely solved with
flight with for the case of the normal
distribution one typically use
who won typically uses a chart with a
limit and then looks for patterns on
excesses of the limit okay but it's
there's very little in terms of non
normal distribution so the question here
is given a manager which we had who had
a process that was not normal in fact it
was log normal could he possibly control
it in some way so here's a theoretical
very quick overview of a theoretical way
of looking at it just a second there we
go
okay we'll start with this and nearly
normal nearly normal log normal and this
one the peak is just a little bit to the
left of the mean that means the vertical
green vertical grey line and the thick
tails is off to the right now what we
find here just a sec ere we are where is
that thing area what we find here is
that okay I have to explain the
confidence intervals charts the purple
line on the top is a confidence interval
of 90% in other words if you draw a
sample there are nine chances in 10 that
it'll be in the purple interval the
purple interval extends from zero to
some natural number the purple refers to
90% and the yellow refers to 80% in the
light blue refers to twenty seventy
percent and by the time you get down to
the bottom you're down to ten percent
any of these things as far as I could
tell could be used to define a process
control chart of the sort that jaco the
sort that I was discussing before
therefore it follows okay sorry so we
have three confidence intervals one goes
from zero to a natural number one goes
from a natural number to infinity and
the other is symmetric about means
symmetric about means means that the
probability of drawing a sample that
falls into the left part of the purple
line with the boundary being the
horizontal line that goes up almost me
with the boundary being the vertical
line the probability of falling into the
left-hand interval is equal to the
probability of falling into the right
hand interval in other words the
symmetry has to do with probabilities
rather than with length of the interval
okay okay any of these could be used to
control the process you just draw
boundaries and then look at the dots
that go out beyond the boundaries if you
get fibers to fine if you get five or
six of them in a row then you know
something's badly wrong because that's
usually improbable it would be seeing a
pattern like that is the equivalent of
0.1 to the sixth that's the probability
of it actually occurring so this can be
managed now let's go down some and look
at this second also log normal here
alpha is 1 and beta is 0.3
whereas above alpha was 1 and beta was
0.1 was point 1 okay and in this
interval you can see that the comp of
the peak is over to this even more
skewed to the left
even more displaced to the left and that
the long tail is even more pronounced
and it goes off to the right notice also
okay now on the confidence intervals the
one saying zero to mm notice that the
starting point
notice that the starting point for the
top one is a little further to the right
than it was before
in other words before it was a three
point something and now it's almost up
to four
okay by the same token the natural
number to infinity confidence intervals
are all a little bit more to the left
this means that the band in which you
can't detect in which you cannot easily
detect changes is much larger or
somewhat larger than it was before your
control has become a little bit less
certain okay
the symmetric about the mean you'll
notice there that there is no purple
light that's because there is no
symmetric confidence interval with a
probability of 0.9 of dropping into the
interval we've completely lost the
ability to check symmetric for to check
whether it fits in to us whether samples
fit in to a symmetric confidence
interval for any probability below point
double eight okay so what we're seeing
is a degradation of possible control
know you can control this process but
not as closely as you'd like to okay
Region three
is very very strange it's almost
counterintuitive just a second come on
guys
okay region three is just about
counterintuitive we're looking at a log
normal distribution with alpha 3 and
beta 3.6 here the mean of this instead
of being 3 or 5 or 6 the way you think
it is this 13,000 way over to the right
the tail is very very small sorry the
tail goes out a very long way and in
this one we lose yet more the here are
the same here are the same confidence
intervals that we've been looking at
before if you have to have symmetric
control of the process
you only get a confidence interval the
point of 7% completely useless if you're
looking at 90% confidence interval you
can only control that the everything
within 2000 has to be accepted and below
2000 again your report is your control
of the process has gotten very much
worse okay now what's the problem what's
the problem here why why and the world
did I put this up here the answer is
that
the answer is that is first to show us
the versatility and necessity of
Mathematica and second is to show that
the usual response to this was just to
say you have to make 90% of your you
have to make 90% of your deliveries on
time or else you'll face an
investigation is completely ineffective
okay almost done okay this third one
very well saved very very quickly we had
a heck of a lot of regulations to look
over and the problem was to check it for
was to check it for consistency in order
to do that you have to find two chapters
two texts divisions that refer to the
same subject and then compare them to
see whether they actually say the same
thing or say something that contradicts
each other the problem is finding these
what we did here was to look locate all
acronyms and DoD have about the same the
same have about the same syntax so we
could locate acronyms which we did and
here we are
okay the hash numbers here locate the
hash numbers here refer to different
chapters it's just a hash of the chapter
title the similarity refers to how many
how many acronyms it has in common in
this case the bottom two pairs had no
acronyms in common on the top two on the
top to the top pair did so for that
reason we would inspect the top and not
the bottom now after applying that to
everything we end up with a histogram
that looks like this for similarities
you'll notice on the left it starts at
zero and it goes on up to the right one
point all means that the two sets of
acronyms are identical and presumably
the two chapters are talking about the
same sort of thing now in practice if
you start at zero point two and
similarity and only look at chapters
that have a similarity of that or
greater then
you've probably gotten all the chapters
that might contradict each other you
don't have to look at the chapters that
have nothing to do with each other and
in practice you could get let's see you
can eliminate ninety seven point nine
percent of all the chapters and what's
left just to show you how much is saved
at the third hour 20 minutes per
comparison taking care of these five
thousand eight hundred and twenty-one
chapters would take about three hundred
workdays of labor which is one of the
reasons why it's never done in the
county on the contradictions if there
are any remain in place okay so one more
slide and we aren't done we have about a
minute to do it
okay many fields require generalists and
generalists introduce hypotheses and you
can see that we had quite a bunch of
hypotheses there what's so is supposed
to do that was basically a literature
search
what does can you control a log normal
process that was mathematics and
exploratory mathematics can you find a
way to eliminate some vast bulk of work
that was text processing language
Mathematica is about the only flang
which I know of it is the only language
I know know of they can provide adequate
support for that can provide adequate
support for such a diverse set of
undertakings so Wolfram language in this
respect is a cognitive enhancer and
we're done
[Applause]